so yesterday I played for you a clip from
this past week's face, the nation program,
CBS, where the interviewer, Margaret Brennan,
I believe her name was, tried to play these
weird semantic games with Bernie Sanders,
maybe under the guise of being a sensible
devil's advocacy.
And it was all about Donald Trump's belligerence
on Iran.
And Bernie rightly had absolutely none of
it.
And he said clearly and plainly bombing Iran
would have been an act of war.
Check out that clip.
I did it earlier in the week and I won't replay
it for you today, but today I have another
one of these just strange attempts to sort
of sandbag Bernie Sanders.
Yesterday was the day of debate.
One part.
One debate, one for the 2020 Democratic primary
is split into two nights.
One night was yesterday, the second night
is tonight.
Bernie Sanders is participating tonight, but
he was interviewed before part one of the
debate yesterday by MSNBC.
Uh, and he was interviewed by Casey Hunt who
I guess was trying to play hardball with Bernie
Sanders in some way.
I don't even really know what it is that she
was trying to do, but she starts trying to
sandbag him about will you get out before
the convention if you aren't going to be the
nominee because some say that you hurt Hillary
Clinton by staying in this thing last time
around, which is not exactly how I remember
it going by the way, which makes no sense
to ask specifically to Bernie if you're not
asking every candidate because Bernie is in
second place.
What about asking every single one of these
candidates with 0.6% or 1.2% support that
are clogging up the stage?
They, they made the requirements, right?
I'm not saying that by virtue of the requirements,
they shouldn't be there.
They made the requirements to be on the debate
stage, but clogging it up time wise and letting
us not really hear any depth from the candidates
that have a shot.
What about asking them are they going to get
out on Monday?
Which many of them should, and this just starts
to get really weird.
And Bernie again, points out are you going
to ask this to every candidate?
What is this line of questioning?
And then when the will you get outline falls
apart on Casey Hunt, she goes with, are you
a Democrat in this completely sarcastic and
condescending way?
Just a really interview.
Take a look at this.
If it's clear that you are not going to be
the Democratic nominee, will you leave the
race before the convention?
I intend to be the Democratic nominee.
But if you're not, you stay it.
And some people say that Hillary Clinton scam.
No.
Some people say that if maybe that system
was not rigged against me, I would've won
the nomination and defeated Donald Trump.
That's what some people see.
So I think we're going to play it out.
I think I am excited.
I am excited.
Donald, are you asking me a lot of every candidate?
Okay, you are not going to win right now.
We are planning to win the Democratic nomination
and a proud of the campaigns we're running
in Iowa and in New Hampshire and I'm proud
of our grassroots support and the fact that
we have the million volunteer.
So I would go right now is the winner.
And by the way, as you may not
poll after poll shows, what against Trump
chose me beating Trump by eight, nine or 10
points.
So we're going to be Trump.
We're going to win the Democratic nomination.
Are you a democrat?
Call somebody number.
Ricardo.
This is a democratic national.
A convection.
A Democratic Primary Hamburg.
All right.
That's an easier answer to that question and
I feel like we got in 2016 Senator Bernie
Sanders.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
She says he hurt Hillary's candidacy.
When I think back to 2016 I don't recall Hillary
being hurt by Bernie.
I remember Bernie being hurt by the DNC.
I Remember Hillary Clinton being hurt by James
Komi.
Sure.
I remember Hillary being hurt in the general
election, uh, partially by her own decisions
about where to campaign and where to not campaign.
This is a really, uh, uh, I don't even know
what to call it.
It's a, it's a soft, so fist attempt to sandbag
Bernie Sanders, uh, by Casey Hunt.
And before yesterday's debate, I'll admit
it had been months since I last watched MSNBC.
I turned it on yesterday before the debate
because I wanted to see how were they previewing
it?
Who is commenting?
Is this type of stuff comment on there now
because it seems to have gotten really, really
bad.
These are not the important questions for
Bernie Sanders.
There are all sorts of questions that could
have been asked to Bernie that would've been
more interesting.
And I understand if you are going to ask Bernie
about this as Gillette brand when she's getting
out, ask Tim Ryan when he's getting out, there's
so many people pulling under 1%.
I mean, Amy Club, a Char Inslee, a Hickenlooper,
Delaney, Gabbert.
I mean, these people are under 1% if not under
2%.
Uh, are we asking them when they're getting
out because they could probably get out Monday
and it would be reasonable.
Bernie will support whoever is the nominee.
We know this.
This line of questioning is absurd.
I'm glad that in the Sunday interview with
CBS and in this one, Bernie is not allowing
himself to be steamrolled with these absurd
questions and the most important thing is
everything that is happening is anti depth
and anti discussing issues.
A debate with 10 on stage each night with
a minute answers and 32nd rebuttals only from
some of the candidates on each question lets
us learn almost nothing about their positions
and about how to fix problems facing us.
This type of interview doesn't create a conversation
where we deepen our understanding of, for
example, Bernie's foreign policy.
I am one of the first to admit Bernie is weakest
on foreign policy relative to other areas.
It would have been great to just talk about
foreign policy in detail.
For example, a, would Bernie be open to alternatives
to Medicare for all that?
In other countries, I've worked really well
talking about the Canadian system or the British
system or whatever.
Right?
I mean, there's substantive stuff that you
can actually play devil's advocate with and
confront Bernie about, which would be useful.
This is, I'm coming up with these just kind
of randomly.
Those would all be more substantive than will
you get out if you're losing before the convention
or are you a Democrat?
I don't know if this stuff is now common on
MSNBC again, because I don't really watch
any of this stuff.
I have no idea.
But I want to hear from you.
Like, is this what MSNBC has become because
it's not great.